[Music]
check
[Music]
chasing this money on a daily doppy came
with a gadget like sandy bros spin spin
sing so handy handsy get underneath gets
handsy
louder i know she was hungry man passed
out to bro that's lovely i'm doing up
shapes all day i ain't talking about so
trick
he really tried to rob me before so man
what did
you go around there oh jumpy what do we
really do is scare and sketch you talk
about this money didn't want to know
when you have a female that's how it
goes i get my click crosstalk no fake
holes
i'm killing this beat straight death row
money in my veins call me diablo
better have my money no pressure bro but
i burn that bridge from a [ __ ] door
man i hate when i see that otp so your
cashless can't get to me
can't make it back in two years and
freeze couldn't be a trap and they went
for me addicted to squares i'm a
different breed could've got chops now
he's all on me i'd rather be
unknown like tea with the brothers of
bees and there's money on me when i wish
you for this money like turner
pop more bottles let's turn up turn it
with a vision like a hunter pull across
to a chest like a candle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that splash you came for the cash be
stopped saying i'm trash now we're
docking no obstacles
[Music]
i'm eating the ian that's family family
family family
granny and girls can be family family
family family i hate that one sunshine
fun of me follow me
follow
[Music]
[Music]
batch they [ __ ] with the squawker we
next stop bringing to the owner like
dick stock
she came to the crib or dressed up she
left the place all sexed up
oh she left the place so sick stop
[Music]
chasing his money on a daily doppy came
with a gizzy like sandy but spin spin
thing so handy handsy girl on her knees
gets handsy
louder i know she was hungry that's
lovely i'm doing up ships all day i
ain't talking man so trick
he really tried to rob me bareface all
slow man what did
we go around there or jump you all they
will do is
you